hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the third of februari today and you're
watching games what news here's the good
stuff that happened today dying light is
gathering itself a heck of a following
with 1.2 million unique players in its
first week alone that fairly large
number counts the players across xbox
one ps4 and PC there's becomes even more
interesting when you consider that the
physical game hasn't even landed in
Europe Australia Asia all the Middle
East as yet that's due to happen later
this month but games in these regions
can grab the title digitally now by
aware of said today the mass effect 4 is
not going to be like Dragon Age
Inquisition while there was some
speculation that mass effect 4 may
borrow heavily from inquisitions
successful template it seems that won't
be the case Bioware's Aaron Flynn said
the main similarities you will see our
larger game areas and both games being
developed on the Frostbite 3 engine he
said that the next Mass Effect will be
drawing on its own history for example
through their plans to recreate the
controversial Mako vehicle Flynn
explains we're very proud of what dragon
age inquisition has achieved but that
does not set a template for what every
other game we make needs to be each game
franchise needs to innovate and improve
their experience based on what's best
for it not just what another game has
success with because well that was
successful finally bungee have announced
what might amount to the biggest
challenge in destiny yet this week
invigorate gaming the team who were the
first to take down raid bosses a peon in
crota will be fighting you if your game
five members of their squad plus Bungie
community manager deej will play a
destiny control match this wednesday at
seven p.m. PDT on ps4 if you can
successfully take down the squad you'll
grab yourself an emblem of legends but
it's probably fair to say it won't be an
easy way
in the last may the odds be ever in your
favor let me know down in the comments
if you reckon you're a good enough gamer
to take on the probe you can head to
gain spot where we've got you on a new
razor blade laptop and the order 1886 is
launch trailer that is it for me today
thanks for tuning in and be sure to
check back same time tomorrow for a
bunch more news things